Tôi số 5 mi tư người ta cho em mới là một bộ nước cửng có nồng độ của các cái ca chiều đã nhớ như là đây trong đó nồng độ của ca chiều xem 2 cửng một người hay còn em chưa biết rồi là dây đi, dám mình nghĩ ngày đến vào còn đi tích nhá, vào còn đi tích là tầm số 1, đi tích dư 1, đi tích dư 1, đi tích ám.
Nhưng mà chua này, vui em mà hai íc này, em dừng vào hai íi này,
vui hai íi em cộp với hai íi,
sẽ bằng chút thầy cả các bạn này mình không lại.
Tung nipes, cuông nhóc thì cộng này không phải khúc nhắm.
Em không chút thầy, vui hai, dừng đi anh này là không phải cung tạm.
Công phải cung tạm này.
Vui em còn chút thầy tiếp anh này,
anh này, nhưng đây là không phải cung 2,
dế em sẽ ra, thế giới là không phải khúc, bơi lắm.